Điều đường trình năng Indonesia đang hình chiương kiến hành trên xích kíu hộ,
tìm kiếm tà mây người mất tiếp sau lửa sản lợd đến nghiệm trọng sox mở lớn,
trên sình nối vô răng găng, chuyển tay ban đồng, tình tây xà và ngày 20 từ tháng 1,
tuy nhiên hoạt động kíu hộ gặp nhiều khó khăn, so để hình thức tạp và điều kiện thời tiết tiếp tục có mở lớn.
Công ngày 20 tháng 1, khẩy sất Indonesia cho biết,
lựa lửa chính năng đã tìm thấy người sau khi thề nạn nhân tại khu vụ xí ra đô,
thuộc hiện tay ban đồng.
Bụ sản lợd đến xả giá sản những ngày bừa lớn kéo dài ở phù vụ tây xà và
các nhà khi tưởng vào cựan phòng trống thiên tay,
cạnh báo nguy câu tiếp tục xả giá sản lợd, zôn đến đất yếu viện gấm lợn mở lớn,
trong khi nguyên vô bận có khả năng kéo dài trong những ngày tới,
chính quyền địa phương đã phuyền cáo người dân tránh xà khu vụ vụ bị anh vùng,
đề đàn báo ăn toàn.
Theo ước tính ban đồng, hàng chục hối nhà của người dân đã bị vui lớp hoàn toàn dưới vụ đất xó tham hóa này.